Kansas does have a chance to get the
final shot here it's in the hands of
Grady dick it's on the way
he's not only a guy that could score him
he's so versatile Johnson lost it again
lots of turnovers early
pass are you serious Big Time finish
yeah he's one of the great type of
damage in the game a really tremendous
14 wins two years ago
feels like it most likely is a really
big year for Kevin Keith wow can this
guy get it off
Adams is looking for the back cut from
Brady hit Harris
dick from way deep another holy cow wow
can completely change the Outlook
heading into the half
Corner three Grady dick
a shot from the corner
[Applause]
Adams playing with three fouls turnover
Here Comes yessifu
has options Grady dick grinds it up and
hits
[Applause]
still a little bit hobbled right now
it's that left
side that's bothering of a great finish
from Grady got to keep those Fortnight
records tight
good ball fake goes that's the basket
puts it in at one where we talked about
that earlier
urging on the sellout crowd here in Waco
looks like Baylor going back to that
1-1-3 and there's Olaf
Kansas going five out
trying to move the ball from side to
side then get downhill good cut by Grady
dick
just a beautiful back cut along the
Baseline
[Applause]
there's a lot
Kansas breaks the pressure